i guess a big part of what recruiters
need to do is is maintaining and
sort of keeping a consistent pipeline
how did you continue to achieve that
firstly the obvious is bringing in
business constantly and knowing your
ratios is key knowing your numbers what
you need to do to hit x
you know and why and um at any given
time i'd be juggling
when i was 360 for example between 8 and
12 vacancies a week
what did you do day in day out to make
sure that you maximize your time
keep it simple like they don't over
complicate it really you've just got to
have
a real one like a checklist every day
every single day before you go is like
what do you want to achieve from that
day
but having a real understanding right
what do i need to get my business to
what does my business need tomorrow
things that you really doubled down on
that you really felt meant that you was
able to
continue increasing your performance and
yeah grow that
to nearly 800 100k billions i think the
first thing is
i didn't over complicate it you know i i
really
from that side i knew what i wanted to
do i set i set a goal out at the start
of the year
and i wanted i had to hear it having
high expectations of yourself
not looking at anyone else you compete
with yourself that's the key thing